ich hab's nicht so mit dem novemberwert
da ist immer so kalt feucht neblig geht
darum fahre im november immer für
mindestens eine woche irgendwo hier
irgendwo etat warm und sonnig ist er und
da habe in den letzten 45 jahren aber
wir doch schon ziemlich alles abgegrast
was möglich ist und wo ich einfach mal
was leisten er sagt ein freund von mir
absoluter geheimtipp sagt der muss tief
andersen mich gehört hochsommer blauer
himmel blaues meer
28 grad im schatten
sibirien
the pod ist aber nicht überprüft und bin
da einfach hingefahren nach nur sieben
rosberg zufrieden ja schon vor augen ist
nicht schön
nur wo sie bis das ist eine stadt der
gegen shao der kläranlage aus wir las
vegas es ist die einzige stadt der
ganzen welt wo sie abstufungen für
trecker treck trecker treck und trecker
trecks trägt ja hobby von dort aus
sofort meinem freund angerufen und
nachdem ich eine halbe stunde lang
beschimpft habe wobei das wort quadrat
folgt granaten trottel noch das
freundlichste war gefragt was soll der
quatsch
wie so oft mit oder her geschickt sagte
oje oje hat merck bist du dem leib
erhalt sibirien verwechselt mit
neuseeland
so wie im jahr dann sei dir verziehen
weil wer hat noch nicht neuseeland und
sibirien verwechsle ich
verwechsle ja dauernd dolly buster dalai
lama ja das ist so ähnlich sein
da ist die nowosibirsk dieser
saison
gewöhnungsbedürftige gurt verständigung
haut super hier die haut super je weil
die rede hat er alle englisch der bürger
spezielle art vor englisch klingt
ungefähr so groß wie youtube oder
prestige
und überall in dem hotel wo er checkt ob
die war dann meistens in der sauna wer
das war der einzige raum der geheizt war
also 14 grad gehabt
sibirische grad ich muss man den
umrechnen game deutschen krautsand ist
so 4 grad
gute vorteil war temperaturbedingt sein
solo zum drinks essen bei williams nicht
hongkong dann sagen dieses marketing
menschen in der sauna
museum ja aber übers essen im hotel also
doch komisch sein da kommst du überhaupt
nix sagen also nikon vor allem deswegen
extra sagen weiß nicht ob ich
bin doch nicht die haben dort zum
frühstück konnte so was gespachtelt
der kellner hock sagt borscht fressen
bloß die verweichlichten moskau weil es
nichts verdrängt diese weicheier die
echten kerle in sibirien die essen nur
er hat das wort dreimal ausgesprochen
und tragen wir dem user dabei ist es
raus gefolgt oder was ein teller mit
bosch
das haus geschafft ist zeigt der gesagt
hat ist so jetzt essen mit zwei drei
flaschen wodka bringt man den dreck
locker runter der ibiza benitez typ sagt
dass es sich nicht auf keinen fall auf
arme bagger mit zwei kellner heute mit
der man kopf integrieren war massa auf
und schütteln mit diesem bosch in den
hals und zwei flaschen wodka hinterher
wer ist sowas vor derartig blümerant ist
mir waren und ich komme dann bloß so
drohe erinnern dass mir irgendwie das
waren 3 75 jährige blond gefärbte hafen
nutzen und die romy backt und die haben
damit mehr kasatschok getanzt
und da denkt doch vorher nächstes jahr
wieder her
[Applaus]